e
all
right I guess I could be a substitute
for
okay uh we'll take up 353
first
so um so who do I have here for 353
hand
that's that's not
exactly accurate okay what you're
because you're the one who wanted us to
have this discussion right I'm I'm sorry
I didn't hear that you're the one who
okay so tell us tell us so I was you the
only one in the
room go for it so I've been talking to
uh gateways who is here last week I mean
the last time when we had the uh thing
and they're having people that have been
turned away for insurance coverage
for uh Down syndrome behavioral therapy
kind of
things and the problem that we've been
seeing is that a a number of down
syndrome kids and we're not talking
about a lot because we only have 20 kids
a year born in the state with
Downs
uh that they aren not necessarily
autistic and and that's the clear code
that that's in the statutes right now
you you need to be down syndrome with
autism in order to get covered
for the behavioral therapy that we're
talking about except that in talking to
the insurance
department we may have an issue that
we're not using the right codes that
there may be other codes that are
applicable in other words you don't have
to be downs and you could be something
else and so I wanted to ask them to come
in and talk about just for a few seconds
what is possible what kind of an
investigation can they look at to find
out where the issue might be because
there may these folks may be covered and
we don't know
it
so hello good morning I'm Michelle
Heaton I'm the director of Life and
Health at the New Hampshire insurance
department so to give a little bit of
background um on this issue the new um
the insurance department has their
consumer services hotline and complaint
process and we receive complaints all
the time about a variety of different
issues we work with consumers to resolve
the issues when there's regulatory
violations and provide them with
information even if it's a plan that we
do not regulate um to date we have not
really received any complaints regarding
this issue about um coverage for kids
with Down syndrome and things not being
covered so from that respect we're not
really sure where the breakdown is some
of so we would encourage anyone who's
having problems with coverage that's
commercial insurance coverage please
come to us and file these complaints so
we can help them work through the
process um as I was talking to
representative spe um one of the issues
is this is going to be very fact
specific so it depends on you know the
type of insurance it the type of
coverage um making sure that it is
commercial commercial plan what are the
um symptoms that the child's
experiencing what type of services are
they trying to access are those services
in network there's a lot of different
variables so without you know the
individual complaints it's kind of hard
to just put out general information to
help people um one of the things we can
do but again it's a very small
population we're talking about here so I
don't know that there was necessarily
anything in our claims database but we
could look up um some claims information
and see kind of if things are being
denied and the reasons for those denials
um another issue is that
if if a child is going to Aba therapy
then the coverage yeah could depend on
how it's being coded to be submitted so
it could be that there are children with
Down Syndrome getting the ABA therapy
but maybe they're duly diagnosed and it
was coded as autism and there's no
reference to Down syndrome so we're not
going to necessarily see that in the
claims um database so um that could be
something that you ask us to do would be
to do um a study to look at coverage for
Down
syndrome um or coverage for services for
children with Down syndrome and at the
denial rates and see if we can come up
with any reasons but again when we're
talking about a really small population
we just don't really know we have't we
may have looked at this I'm not sure I'd
have to go back and look um because it's
been a while since we were talking about
this bill we may have done some initial
work on it but um nothing really stuck
out if we did but we can go back and
revisit that and see is is there you
know certain codes that are having a
higher denial rate but um there are
limits in our data because of the small
population here and in the way it's been
coded so it could be being coded in a
way that is being covered and it's not
going to show up as a denial in our
system so really the best way would be
if there are people being denied
coverage file complaint we can work
through the specifics of that case okay
I have some uh people that have work
with gateways you know who they are
they're they deal with Down syndrome and
autism kids and and adults and I think I
can get them to give me some people we
can touch base with to find out how
they've been denied or whatever and then
you could possibly work through what
happened yeah we'd be happy to do that
and we do that all the time for Anytime
there's coverage issues who is helping
providers and consumers work through how
do we get coverage for this is there
coverage is this covered why or why not
but at this point without having a
specific belly button as it were as we
say in the biz
uh you don't think it's worthwhile to go
looking at data just on any kind of
thing you could look at uh proactively
yeah I mean we could but I don't know I
mean without looking it's more Jason's
territory
um but I'm not sure how much data
there's going to be there and if it's
really going to tell us where the issue
is because it's a small population I
think the most efficient way would
probably be reaching out to those people
sending them our way and giving us some
specifics so that we can look at those
specifics and find out what exactly is
going on there okay I will do that thank
you okay so um that's great um so the
only thing just to uh educate myself
what what is it that we do cover now
what is a what's in our statue what's
the ways is it uh is autism treated as a
mental health issue or is it treated as
a physical so for all commercial plans
mental health treatment must be covered
so that covers it's treated as mental
health it is treated as mental health um
autism is is a mental health disorder
that there is treatment and that's where
typically ABA therapy is used okay it's
in the DSM right yep okay and when we're
talking about um Down syndrome there are
a variety of different treatments
depending on um the particular issues
that the individual is experiencing so
we do also mandate um early intervention
services for all children so anytime
there's developmental delays I vaguely
remember that statute yeah so anytime
there's developmental delays um that
would cover speech language um
therapy um occupational therapy Physical
Therapy a lot of those issu issues that
also kind of overlap sometimes with
autism so anytime there's developmental
Down syndrome or down syndome to down so
it it depends on what type of issues the
child or individual is experiencing but
for the most part we already have
mandates in place and this would be all
part of the essential health benefits
that are required in the individual and
small group so as far as you're
concerned in terms of the the mandates
we've already done in terms of the
mental health a and then B that in terms
of early
intervention and early intervention that
we've already passed we already have a
health a mandate already on the statutes
yeah so if there are gaps I we want to
work through those because it could be
something just not being coded right or
it's not being submitted properly but if
there is a misunderstanding maybe with
carriers and what they need to cover
we'd be happy to issue additional
guidance to clarify to the extent
there's any what you just said was very
important I think if the
practitioner doesn't know what all the
code what the appropriate codes are they
may not be coding it right so you have
the ability to go out and tell them you
know you're supposed to be using these
codes or for these conditions and those
kind of things yeah in the past we've
issued bulletins um we've done a couple
recently with respect to mental health
um mental health practitioners and uh
Primary Care behavioral health model
issuing guidance of you know these are
generally the types of codes and direct
carriers to make sure their providers
know the proper codes to use to um have
those claims
covered because sometimes it can vary
too by the insurance carrier and in
their provider contract and manual it
usually specifies how they um need to
code stuff to have things covered so the
uh early intervention statute um would
you mind tonight emailing me that RSA
just to remind me because I think we
should be put that in the blur in our in
our the committee report that we should
say that the statute does exist and if
it is not being effective for if if some
practitioners feel that that this is not
doing what it's doing then then we need
we we need to be brought to our
attention the Department's attention so
we can address it so that if futureal
legislation would be if if it became
clear that that statute is somehow not
covering um these kids yep I'll will be
happy to do that and sense get i'll s to
both of you yeah well I'm looking for
you you know
to to write the uh the committee report
okay and so I'm giving you something to
put in that committee report I'm writing
the report yeah yeah you tag your at
okay then okay so but that and in it I
want you to put in how you know that we
need the communication to the department
on you know where where there has been a
problem with when somebody got a
rejection or whatever they need to
commit Comm unicate that and um and but
more importantly that we we already have
a statute for Early
Intervention when we say early
intervention how many years old are we
talking
about um I think our specific mandate
statute goes
from birth until three years old but um
it would still be covered as part of
essential health benefits so our early
intervention statute is part of our
Benchmark plan and was um in place prior
to the ACA but um the general um ehb
requirements would require those covered
past those services to be covered past
three years to the extent that they're
medically necessary I think at some
point and it would probably depend on
the child but once they get to a certain
age I think and I'm not a doctor so I
could be a little off on this but those
interventions are not as um successful
after a certain age so I think that's
why back in the day we had put that
three years but um essential health
benefits would have to require beyond
that three years to the extent it's
medically
necessary you'll write that in an email
to help her
out yes I will follow up with an email
do I use this you're going to have to
tell me how to what goes into one of
these reports I have no I've never seen
one okay well oh okay that is true so
basically the motion is either you know
recommended or not recommended for
future legislation so we we're pretty
much uniformally everything is going to
be not recommended because it it well I
want to see what there is for us right
what you say is is that as as the bill
has written as it is right now all right
it this no we don't recommend this what
we the committee does recommend what we
do feel so strongly in support is we
need better communication from providers
who are
experiencing uh refusals from insurance
company to communicate with the
department and so that and so then then
the department will know whether we need
to look at um this the statue in the
future years but there was there was one
piece I want wanted to the one piece
where I go and find somebody who has
been denied and the insurance department
tells me why they were denied good luck
finding that person I I I do think I
have access you think you have right
okay gateways tell tells me that they
will provide those people right right
yeah we'd be happy to work through them
to make sure coverage is appropriately
let's see what they come up with
happening and to the extent that there's
any um confusion about what's required
you know we're happy to follow up with
the carriers to make sure they
understand what the law is and they're
following it but to the extent if we
find something that is some kind of Gap
and off the top of my head I'm not
seeing where that would be but if we do
find that you know we'll definitely be
coming back to close that loophole with
you guys so what you're you just
volunteered for is that you're going to
go find a real life story and you're
going to get it to the department and
then once you've seen once the
Department's got it and once you've
dealt with it then the department can
come back in a couple weeks and tell
us okay so that it has to happen by
before October 17th that you need to
okay okay exactly no I said put it put
the pedal in the metal and and get see
what you can you can you can get and
that way we'll have a real life
antidotal story on how um what's going
on and if I can't get anybody that then
we'll just go with what we said before
about the uh about the essential health
benefits and the early intervention and
all the rest of that correct okay that
seem make
sense okay thank you very
much I think all right we'll move on
from
1571 okay so who's here from
all right um so I I see the sponsors
here so why don't you come on up
days before we had these microphones and
cameras and you know let's say be
pre-o uh when when Commerce had
subcommittees
um we wouldn't be sitting in our seats
we would all be sitting in a corner and
we all be kind of collect together and
we and it's a
conversation right people are not
testifying it's a conversation and it's
a back and forth and try to figure out
you know where we are where we should go
you know what's the right answer here so
um we'll try to treat it like that but
obviously we have microphones so
everybody at home can watch so turn your
microphone on and okay so um if I
understand this bill
correctly is that um anybody can test
their blood
sugars yes and I I I'm just I don't know
if you right I I was just pre just uh
diagnosed with pre-diabetic I'm 6.4 in
my A1C and uh and so now I I went out
and bought a fast kit um which
everything was real cheap until they see
how much they charge for the little the
tabs and I found I said how do people
afford this he said well most people get
their insurance comps to pay for
it but they wouldn't pay it for me
because I'm
pre-diabetic problem number one I got to
get my A1C at the
6.5 then they will pay for those those
tabs and boy the prices are all over the
of these little tabby things it was the
package is 50 and um both U Walmart was
even more expensive than than uh than
who was the it was the was the pharmacy
Walgreens they were like
$80 and for them and uh then but then I
found I got I can get them from Amazon
for
40 so you did your homework very well
chairman right yeah so I I do know the
price is though so the issue now is that
okay so we that theoretically anybody
who's already a diabetic has been is can
get test kits for free okay that's
that's that's what I'm could I respond
okay so you can get test kits for free
if you have insurance coverage right and
um it is recommended that you do that I
wouldn't say everybody's getting a test
kit no I'm saying people could right
when I and then you know obviously this
summer I talk to people and I'm I'm
amazed the amount of people who test
first start testing really religiously
and then after a while they decline in
they're testing themselves and we know
that that is a very common circumstance
that when people are first diagnosed
with diabetes they're generally quite
concerned and um probably
scared and compliance with recommended
testing is pretty good
and then over time people do it less and
one of the reasons people do it less is
it's not particularly comfortable to
finger stick over and over it's it's a
small finger stick it literally is less
than a pin prick in a way it is a pin
print but your fingers do get more
sensitive over time and depending
on how much information is beneficial to
that patient and how um inconsistent
their blood sugars are the more
inconsistent their blood sugars are the
more frequently they should check to
help inform how they're managing their
diabetes and depending on what type of
Diabetes you have and how it's
treated it might be recommended I'm not
exaggerating to test your blood sugar a
dozen times a day well that's more than
one finger per
finger for the rest of your life um so
there are finger stick monitoring is
very informative very valuable
and not without
problems right cuz the the difference
between the the blood sugars versus A1C
the A1C is looking at that whole your
you know it's it's much more Global and
so I do have my test next week and and
I'll be testing my a andc and because I
put myself on on that fora
and depending on how your body is
responding to your good attention to
addressing
this A1C is a good broad measure of how
well someone's diabetes is being
managed targeting to get it under six or
5.8 is I've been retired a couple years
I just wanted to verify that I
remembered the numbers correctly
um sometimes though A1C doesn't
represent the irregularity of blood
sugars throughout the
day it's not exactly an average but it
sort of acts like an average and so if
you're having a lot of high numbers and
a lot of low numbers your A1C could
actually be reasonable but you're not
feeling very good and you're not
preventing complications you're not well
so A1C is useful but without frequent
awareness of your fluctuating blood
sugar CA fluctuation it's not enough to
say you're doing the job your pancre is
not working at certain times of the day
okay so these monitors that are
everybody wants that you want do one I
assume this legislation is your
mandating that anybody should be able to
get one of these so it said whether it
didn't say pre-diabetic didn't say
diabetic it looked like it was pretty
wide open yes so the intent of the bill
is that whatever approach to blood sugar
monitoring the patient would benefit
from would be covered so the bill draft
includes the testing that you're
describing with a device and a
disposable test strip you can only get
one blood sugar result per strip right
so as you note the cost of them becomes
very significant over time the cost of
the devices is not a big deal to most
people 25 bucks it's the
ongoing test strips um so the intent of
the bill is to cover both the that
option those options and to cover
continuous glucose monitors which are
wearable devices they're essentially the
size of a quarter how much are those um
I'm going to defer to can I invite Liz
yes oh absolutely Liz come on up help me
out um so the cgms attach they penetrate
the skin slightly right um depending on
the device you wear them for 7 to 14
days and then replace them and you can
read your blood sugar from that
instantly I can just take my phone and
go like that and it tells me what it is
right now no finger prick
involved right now in regard to cost
there's uh you know these continuous
blood glucose monitors have been updated
over the years so I'm going to give you
the cost of the Dexcom 7 which is the
most recent one and also the freestyle
lebre which is a which is another one
produced by another company and the
average retail price for a pack of three
sensors which is a 30-day Supply is
between $152 and
$35 depending where it's
purchased so it really it literally can
vary from Pharmacy to pharmacy because
many of these devices are are sold
within pharmacies uh Costco price a lot
of individuals have gone to Costco if
they have a membership there uh is
$185 um good RX which is a place that a
lot of us look at when we're trying to
get economical um uh devices is about uh
$72 um $72 for for a for a 30-day Supply
$72 for 30 days yes okay now if we go to
the freestyle Libre which is made by uh
Abbott the price of that one through
Costco is a for one pack of two sensors
these can actually be worn for 14 days
okay um the cost of that uh again
through Costco is about
$170 and through good RX it's about
$80 okay so I would just
encourage factor that out over a year
times the rest of your
life um so I took the initial 152 that
Liz said for the Dexcom for 30 days
that's over $1,800 a year for that
sensor it's extremely valuable to the
patient and frankly to the Health Care
system because we're reducing
complications that are very expensive
and very much adverse effect on quality
of
life but it's a lot of money for people
to keep up with and I would also note
that while sensors have
improved they do sometimes fail they
don't always say stuck on and you can't
reapply that sensor when it comes
detached you have to get a new one so
these numbers per month are the least
amount per month that it would be
right the other thing is is for each of
the sensors um it could communicate
medicate your blood sugar in two
different ways one of them is a thing
called a reader which is a device that
um you put it up against your sensor and
it reads your blood sugar uh those
average about anywhere from $150 to $200
a year or if a person has got a
compatible cell phone okay they can
actually have that information
downloaded into their cell phone uh and
it allows you know individuals know
where their blood sugar is but it would
also let's say we have someone who has
some cognitive impairment for some
reason it would allow another individual
to also know where that blood sugar is
and then get in contact with the person
who's cognitively impaired and if you
know the blood sugar is going too high
what's going on have you taken your
medicine would wouldn't they be getting
an insulin pump at that point wouldn't
they no no no let's say we have somebody
what percentage of people have insulin
pffs what it's a rather small so what's
the diff so I me because Mo I think when
even when I first saw this leg
legislation I was thinking it was
insulin pump I didn't realize it was
just testing okay so the question is um
do insurance companies cover what do
they cover
now okay the the insurance companies
okay uh Will C cover insulin pumps and
they will also cover CGM continuous
blood glucose monitoring yeah if you
meet certain criteria
6.5 a A1c 6.5 yes and an A1C 6 so this
legislation is only for all those people
who are
pre-diabetics no because one of the
other uh requirements for insurance
coverage is usually you have to be
treated with insulin and
the majority put the
mic one of the other requirements of
insurance companies to cover cgms
generally is you have to be treated with
insulin and the majority of people with
type 2 diabetes and everybody with
pre-diabetes are not treated with
insulin yeah but how how what what what
is the threshold that insurance
companies
accept the threshold if it's not 6.5
which I was told you are correct about
that but that's only one of the factors
to so you saying insurance company has
another requirement other than 6.5 so
let's say your A1C is 7.2 okay so you
meet the threshold that you've just
noted right but you're a person with
diabetes who is not being treated with
insulin you are being treated with some
other medication that may oral maybe
metformin or maybe an injectable
medication but it's not
insulin we're very fortunate
today um you you began this meeting
going back in time to the pre-co days if
I go back in time to my early days as a
diabetes educator in the 1980s and 1990s
we didn't have very many tools in the
toolbox for treating diabetes now we
have a lot more pharmaceutical options
that work extremely
well but one of the trade-offs of
working very well to control blood sugar
is the patient needs to be very aware
not to have it overcorrect and go too
low and of course there are a lot of
variables that affect blood sugar what
you eat how much you eat your stress
level your activity level how well you
slept
um hormone changes with monthly
Cycles um I mean there's like a list of
25 variables that affect blood sugar
those are the most common ones that I
just said so even if somebody takes the
same medication dose and time day after
day after day and appears to have a
fairly predictable routine you know
maybe they have a 9 to-5 death job their
activity doesn't fluctuate a lot on
those
weekdays even so their blood sugar could
be less predictable than you would
expect it to be and if they
can't efficiently and affordably monitor
it then they can't respond to those
changes in blood sugar in a safe and
timely manner so the insurance coverage
if you have type 1 diabetes meaning you
must be taking insulin to treat it is
good but insurance coverage for people
with type 2 diabetes or pre-diabetes
for testing supplies is not good at all
it's not consistent it's not uh adequate
but it's it's preventative
medicine all right this is not curing
you this is preent this is getting you
knowledge knowledge is you know
important knowing your status knowing
what your what's going on is important
okay but that when you look at our
health insurance mandates and that's
what this bill is this is a health
insurance mandate when you look at our
mandates our mandates were where
insurance was uh that we had decided
that this was a something that really
needed to happen and insurance companies
were erratic in enforcement so you take
the most famous one which is
uh
monographies okay we mandate
mography and because we think it's so
important there's no co-pays or
deductible from
colonoscopy okay these are preventative
medicines they're preventative
treatments they definitely have a uh and
and I would say I was been here on Long
long enough I remember when the bill the
issue was that the that the mamography
was it had to be a year and a day you
know the get had to be a year and
a day you know that the year so you know
it was that minutia of that mandate you
know we had to revisit it and let alone
now we had to change the type of machine
from the 2D to the 3D and and uh we had
that legislation that that one insurance
company had a little push back on so
those these are mandates of mography you
know these kind of things the health
issues and there's probably more I'm
just not really thinking about it at the
moment but that is very unusual for the
legislature to step in and say this is
appropriate care okay and that and so
that if we know that people these these
things such as these test kits and
things are available we know these
monitors these patch monitors are
available
and the insurance companies are saying
okay we're they give any different one
all right this legislation will only
affect um a very small portion of those
who are
insured we won't affect anybody who's
Medicare we won't affect anybody who is
Medicaid we won't affect anybody who has
a large
employer we're only affecting small
employers who already seem incredibly
you know think that health insurance
premiums
are a huge major punch on their budgets
okay on their hiring people they
literally make a decision to hire
somebody based upon whether they can
afford what kind of health insurance
they're going to give that employee
that's small employers so what we want
to say is is this the cost and this
benefit that you were describing and I
certainly hear you I certainly hear that
that that
you know I know myself all right that
that the different times a day that I
test
myself you know um you know and
certainly I you know I'm I'm all over
the map with my numbers okay there's no
consistent numbers and you think oh
you're no you know you I started out was
say I'm just going to do the fasting
right first thing in the morning okay
well you know only once did I ever break
a hundred because in most people with
pre-diabetes you're fasting blood sugar
is your best blood sugar of the day and
but I'm supposed to be under 100 I'm
supposed to be under 100 now I used to
be 130 now I am under 130 but then since
you mov the number to 100 only once with
my fasting have I broken that okay and I
have stopped drinking sodas all right I
know more ginger ale you know everything
is Diet this and diet that and I'm
eating 45 Calorie bread slices and I
tried the keto and that was not that was
not going to work for me but but I have
done everything possible and and I and I
convinced my doctor that that you know
6.4 that you put put me on the metform
and so I will be getting my test so I'm
I'm excited to hear what my say my A1C
is going to be come October 1st okay but
not withstanding that to mandate
this to tell all small employers
insurance companies to mandate this for
people who are
pre-diabetic or pre or just should know
these
numbers that is it is in the scheme of
things of I think of all the things that
people should be doing in terms
healthwise and how we eat and what we do
you know is is is this worth that bird
I'd like to make a comment I kind of
agree about the
pre-diabetic but the type one diabetic I
mean the type two diabetic that's being
treated with some drug other than
insulin I I think it's much more
and we've seen and heard throughout our
life and on committees here what happens
if you don't pay attention when you are
you are diabetic you're type one
diabetic if you don't pay attention to
that the side effects are kidney
problems and everything else so if we
limit the bill so the question you were
asking and I'm not sure you guys will be
answered because we can get the
Department to help us out the question
you you you have offered up is that the
issue is uh that fromone who is is
diagnosed is diabetic um they are not
able to get this monitor this thing this
thing you want uh and and uh we got to
figure out how many people are in that
position and then whether this we this
is a mandate that we need to pass and I
think the insurance department will be
able to speak to some of those numbers
yeah and and I do just want to say I
appreciate the distinction and concern
between pre-diabetes and type 2
diabetes um however if you treat
pre-diabetes
vigorously I used to say to my patients
who were puzzled about what's
pre-diabetes don't I either have it or
not have it I'd say if you treat
pre-diabetes as if you have full-on
diabetes you can largely prevent or at
least greatly
delay getting the blood sugar numbers
that are diagnostic of diabetes because
when you change lifestyle and reduce
your numbers as you're working hard to
do your body becomes less insulin
resistant it becomes more able to manage
blood sugar
so I think we have two separate but
maybe parallel considerations here
there's value to this monitoring for
people with pre-diabetes
there's probably greater more essential
value to people with type 2 diabetes who
don't take insulin but will develop
complications of diabetes if they don't
have the
capacity with the right resources to
manage the blood the diabetes
effectively and control their blood
sugars okay if I could just make a
comment um it's in regard to individuals
with type two diabetes that are not on
insulin they uh I'm think thinking about
the ones specifically that are on what
we call a selfon Ura which is a type of
pill for diabetes these have been around
for years and years and years and um
these cause the pancreas to produce a
continuous amount of insulin until when
we get into our older years they no
longer work very well and then people
end up um sometimes on insulin not
always but sometimes on insulin these
self a
Urias uh can cause low blood
sugar uh and if after many years of
having diabetes many individuals both on
selfon uas but also on insulin lose the
ability to recognize low blood
sugar and they are fine one minute
cognitively impaired within a relatively
short period of time because their blood
sugar has dropped so low and there isn't
enough sugar getting to the
brain and they can get to a point of
having a
seizure I got you let me hear
one obviously we hoping this patient is
under proper Medical Care Y and I have
no doubt that a
physician can write that prescription to
require this monitor that you're looking
for so we're not talking about these
those people with this legislation
because those people are getting covered
the doctor all the doctor has to do is
write that prescription and the
insurance company will write it now if
you've believe that the insurance
company won't write
it okay that then we have a problem but
in my mind that um given that everybody
is different everybody if there's a
place where a physician is concerned
about what's going on with the patient's
Health okay but if you're thinking that
you're going to give this skill to a
patient for them to self diagnose and
say boy I got this problem and I need to
be dressing it simp simply because I'm
following these numbers or not we all
know people once they have these things
these test kits they're testing or being
resourceful and doing it on a timely
fashion or regular basis drops off we
agree to that in the beginning so I'm
all I'm doing right now is trying to
rationalize you know where the insurance
companies should be covering it and we
then cross our fingers and hope aren't
we saying that for at least in my mind
and and forgive me for not jumping onto
the uh
pre-diabetic aspect of it but in the
type two case yes these things are not
usually prescribed or I don't think they
have access to the insurance if they are
type one guys they got everything yeah
we don't this is not we're not worried
about those this is type this is type
two this is this is just strictly the
type two right is we get them the test
kits the the appropriate whatever
they're called test kits and everything
else and we we mandate that the
insurance has to cover it if they are
diagnosed with type two diabetes they
get it and if the patient doesn't want
to do anything with it and I've known
people like that that that's their thing
we can't help that but we should be able
to get him the test kits I that's what
we want to find out I I personally
believe based upon what I learned that
yes the insurance companies cover it yes
so a couple things the situation that
Liz described of low blood sugar
hypoglycemia unawareness that the
patient no longer symptomatic they don't
get physical cues to tell them they're
dropping and you responded that then
they would be eligible for
CGM they would be with prescription
however they would have to have some
kind of episode that put them at
considerable risk in order for it to be
known that they were having hypoglycemia
on awareness so if that person is
driving while they have low blood sugar
people with low blood sugar drive like
there at DWI you're you're not a capable
driver when your blood sugar is
profoundly low but if you don't know
it's dropping and it's dropping abruptly
you have no warning yeah but how does
this if you have a CGM it alarms you
okay point is that this is this is a
proactive this is a proactive patient
trying to try to head that off right to
yes to head that off and and and your
assumption is if we if we just give it
to them for free then everyone will do
it no the point being is is that no the
person doesn't really know that know
they're heading that way you know
they're if they if they're going to get
to their doctor's office every year and
they're getting their A1C every year
you'll be in the same place that I am is
watching it climb climb climb climb okay
and then and then you'll be but in terms
of having an incident you know holy moly
no this bill doesn't do anything about
someone who's having an incident out of
the blue well it would because if people
were wearing the CGM no but why would
they they be wearing it because they a
person with diabetes who wants to manage
their blood sugar well and in a timely
manner and be safe for them and the rest
of
community um and I also wanted to note
that there's a drop off in frequency of
blood sugar monitoring with finger stip
test I I heard with continuous glucose
monitors the majority of people who use
cgms continue to use them indefinitely
and benefit from them regularly it
doesn't drop off in the same way that it
does with finger sticks okay great let's
let's hear from the insurance okay
thanks cuz we're running tight on time
here okay thank you sorry to cut you
guys
morning good morning Mr chair uh for the
record my name is Jason AIS director of
Health Economics New Hampshire insurance
department and I really really hope that
you go from pre-diabetes state to the
non-diabetic state that's great so stay
on track we're all hoping for the P so
um the department published a report um
in response to the request of the board
uh this committee and we're here to
answer any
questions okay yeah I'll let you open up
okay well need to say the report show it
mandate if if that's your interpretation
what you repeat them numbers so we have
it in unfiled yeah so we we try to model
this very complicated study that seems
simple on the surface but it really is
indeed not um to try to identify the the
previous eligible population who is who
is currently getting um benefits for
this service what the marginal cost was
so what the the per capita cost for per
year for each patient was and then try
to interpret the legislative intent of
the bill is in its current form to try
to predict or offer a prediction for
this board to look at the expansion of
the new eligible population then we went
on to try to predict I think answer a
question that you just had in the
previous testimony you know what
proportion of the new eligible
population might take up this new
benefit oh wow I can get one of these
they look great and it's covered with no
cost sharing I want one right but
presumably not 100% of the population
the expanded population would so we just
modeled it based on the previous rate of
uptake which is approximately
26% of of um type 1 diabetics and type
two diabetics on
insulin so we presume that because of
the Acuity of the diabetes was a main
driver for the uptake rate that that
would be an assumption that would be
reasonably met 26% so we modeled the all
of the statistics that are in the report
on that and that's what you see I think
the approximate annualized cost was
about
$1,380 a year for all parts of um the
legislation including two visits to um a
diabetes educator for import guidance on
how to use the device it's noteworthy
that I think in the bill it mentioned
three visits over an
18month period but because the lens of
this report was a 12-month period we
took 2third of that which was two visits
so that plus the the device and the
supplies was approximately had a median
cost of about
$138 okay a year all right now
um what do we know about when it is
being covered I mean what what in terms
of insurance companies and and what is
do we have is it true that
some that they all required you have to
be an insulin patient to be able to get
these so the first bullet point in the
executive summary me mentioned an
important concept that I think I after
hearing the uncertainty from your
interpreters I think it's worthy to
mention here that in 2022 we did a
fiscal note for I think when this was an
LSR and we only had the 2022 data in
that data we saw that 100% of the
population in the claim in the
commercial fully insured market and some
self-insured um was entirely type 1
diabetics but that changed and it
migrated in 23 and we saw that there was
now a population of type 2 diabetics on
insulin that were in that population and
that Peak our interest so we started
looking at um language and medicure
guidance for coverage for this and
indeed began to note a parallel
migration away from more um in intensive
insulin therapy indications to less
insulin requirements for coverage so I
think it was three for Medicare coverage
for ex as an example um a tangental
example because this is not com in the
commercial space but it was required
that three multiple daily injections of
insulin were required for Medicare
coverage and then as of April in 2024
just recently that went to one and
that's where it currently stands now for
CMS guidance for Medicare coverage you
still have to be on one insulin
injection for for benefits okay and that
and that's and so uh you're saying for
Medicare that's also the Medicare
requirement for a type two diabetic yes
to get this for free you have to have be
getting an insulin product right
okay all
right I think it's also worth mentioning
that you know as
treatment treatments for diabetes
involve the medical guidance and the
medical guidelines for coverage are also
going to to evolve so I think that's
kind of what we saw in our report as
well is when we look from one dat year
to the next we've seen that evolution of
how you know coverage is Shifting
because of um standards
changing
okay
um could you be getting one of these
under what is
it I remember this is kind of the
infamous one of the categories that we
have on health insurance is it's
supplies or it's medical
equipment is like hearing aids were
originally under that category yeah
communicated in a narrative form in the
report was we address that that some
some devices are are the the benefits
are administered through the pharmacy
benefit whereas for others through the
medical medical benefit under the DME or
durable medical equipment durable
medical that's it there we go yeah and I
mean I think you know that varies not
only just with cgms devices but also
insulin pump therapies and there are
lots of other examples and that
nonstandard approach can be problematic
probably for for carriers and providers
alike oftentimes is migration from among
manufacturers to demand it those
benefits be administered for their
device via one versus the other Pathway
to to achieve optimal reimbursement
rates I think is probably one of the
targets yes car I I have a question If a
person is a type 2 diabetic and they're
taking one of those alternative
medications that means they do need
their blood sugar
controlled and for some reason I don't
know what why you would take uh insulin
versus one of these other medications
but why is that considered
something that it seems as if the
coverage says okay you're on this other
medication but you don't need to be
monitored as much as you would if you
were on insulin but you are on
medication and you do have a blood sugar
problem so why are we
not why is that separated out that's a
good question it's it's at the heart of
this issue I think that diabetes
essentially means to siphon it's it
means hypoglycemia
as a proxy but really the the highest
clinical utility the clinical utility
for these devices that got them to
breakthrough onto the market was their
protective effect against
hypoglycemia you can see a a proxy of
that in the the indication the previous
indications for hypoglycemic aware
unawareness so it's really protective
against that indeed it has the highest
clinical utility one which precipitates
the coverage for this marginally
expensive device the question it you
gets your question in in future
questions about how protect or how much
clinical utility from a quantitative
standpoint is there for hyperglycemia
it's not worthy that there would be two
distinctly different utility curves for
both hyp hypoglycemia and hyperglycemia
and that's what that's the challenging
decision for this committee and it's
it's really verging on cryptic because
not a lot of people know what you curves
look like okay well I'm and I keep
telling people I'm not a doctor and
unfortunately I have to feel like I'm
practicing as a doctor sometimes here um
so let's do it in my simple terms is
that um you you're over 6.5 you're
already you're in the diabetic category
okay um does these monitors have an
alarm system to suddenly tell you you're
hypoglycemic you're you're having an
event okay so then then uh we the
interest would be how many people who
are are are who are are been defined as
type two and are not monitoring at
all the prevalence of unmonitored type
other words and and and know I guess we
would I guess we can't tell how many are
not monitored but we could certainly see
how we you know how much of people who
are uh taking advantage
the the say this insulin people who take
insulin and who are because I I have a
sneaking suspicion that even people who
are taking
insulin they don't you know they they
they they are so confident in themselves
they know what they're doing I mean I
let's say I know a lot of people who
have type one and those type ones they
they know their bodies you know they
really know their bodies but I I can't
say a lot about type two because you
know it's it's it's late onset so issue
is
um Carri was saying is what if you're
you know if you're really on really a
diabetic shouldn't you be able to get
one of these monitors if nothing else
that if you were to you know Tap Out and
because you're you're all of a sudden
your pancreas just you know was really
sluggish and really not doing its job so
table one we we aim to communicate that
in the report about 37% of all Di
diabetics take at least one insulin
injection daily and approximately 30% of
type 2 diabetics take at least one daily
insulin
injection so weall that it's it's
insulin or um the previous testimony
Shar that sulan neides and other
non-insulin even metformin can cause
relative hypoglycemia but insulin
without question is the most powerful
antihypoglycemic agent
um but we we put those statistics in
there for the context of this report so
you could understand who how we Define
the eligible population the percentage
of the diabetic population taking
insulin okay um and so before we do end
this and then and and get back again
um most of the time when we do health
insurance mandates is we put some uh
guard
rails and in terms of how do we narrow
it and how do we you're doing it so
right now
um I guess I and I guess I want to know
what the insurance companies are
offering to people in terms of what you
know what they where what their status
is and what they're able to get um do uh
if if somebody instead of having right
now obviously the legislation is to give
it to them for free no deductible no
co-pay do nothing and and that's almost
an anathema to this committee in this
committee we do expect the patient to
have a little skin in the
game so is there something other things
I mean I don't know what we ended up
doing with hearing aids but is are other
things that are comparable that had the
same U health insurance mandate in terms
of those kind of uh
Governors I'm not sure I think I heard a
message I we have one one of the major
Med carriers here so I don't want to
speak for them but in as a preliminary
measure in creative this report we query
the five major Med carriers to ask them
to share and they they willingly share
their guidance and I believe all of them
required some form of insulin therapy
for coverage for this and all diabetic
po I got over that threshold okay okay y
so and then when they require that is
there a co-pay or deductible even if
they are on on insulin is it is it free
like this like this bill so in actually
maybe we'll have Anem okay yeah in the
report we included c a table with CAU
sharing yeah and and hum me just send
the report out to all of us again cuz
did you have the report I do remember
getting it yes so and I remember
scanning it but I can't say that I read
it closely all of the claims for 2023 we
saw Zero do of cost sharing there there
were a yeah median cost sharing was was
really really low so the cost sharing
buring as it currently stands is is very
very low okay that's in a table in the
report all right great okay thank you
you have any more questions for him or
Sabrina I'm still a bit hung up
on what I was mentioning before if
somebody is
a diagnosed type 2
diabetic which means that eventually I I
assume and I I don't know the
progression of how this works if they
don't take care of it they're going to
be a full-on diabetic and if they don't
take care of that they're going to end
up really really with
problems why I I don't understand the uh
the the calculation that goes into
saying well you are in in fact diabetic
but we're not going to help you with the
monitoring the way we would with just
one injection of diabetes even though
you are on
drugs I that's a good question and that
may not be a question for you well I'm
I'm not sure that that I would
characterize it that way because it's
important to note that and I'm a fan of
Representative Damon's legislation and
continuous glucose monitoring I have one
my daughter has one there's High utility
to it it's important to note that that's
not blood glucose monitoring and it may
not necessarily be true that they don't
have ability to
monitor their glucose they could they do
have robust benefits for blood glucose
monitoring which is a much more
directive
pathway continuous glucose monitoring
sensors don't measure blood glucose they
meant to interstial fluid glucose
concentrations that's a proxy for blood
glucose that's important because it's
not known that intertial high intertial
glucose concentrations cause any of the
disease States associated with diabetes
like blindness kidney disease and lower
leg amputations rather
hypoglycemia which means high sugar in
the blood or high glucose in the blood
causes that so A more directive way
allbe it inconvenient painful and
sometimes dirty of a way is to use blood
glucose testing this is a more that's
right which is cross-sectional right now
what's my blood sugar it didn't tell you
what your blood sugar was in AR no it's
moment at the moment at the moment or
what it is going to be in an hour but
continuous glucose monitoring sensor is
a great Innovation I tried to describe
that in the report how that became
innovated but it wasn't until strong
improvements in the correlation between
fluid glucose concentrations and blood
glucose concentrations became acceptable
for that to get FDA approved and once
that happened all right it's a great
proxy albe it a little bit more less
cost effective than finger sticks but
presumably more comfortable Accord
According to some right more more up to
be get to test it that's right and I I
lwed um representative Damon's um point
that she made about compliance and the
drop
off you know the current state of
knowledge about cgms is is is
constrained and some some might say
plagued by publication bias that
epidemiological data is really lacking
right now on on the the benefit and
reduced relative risk for long-term
complications associated with diabetes
from CGS monitoring versus blood glucose
but that's coming soon and so that's not
a trivial a trivial Concept in this
debate but type two diabetics have the
opportunity to test with their blood
sugar which we I would call that a close
substitute or maybe cgms inversely might
be a close substitute to blood glucose
monitoring it's a fabulous
Innovation great thank you thank you all
right you you have another question no
okay all right great all right
Sabrina
sure I just wanted to respond to
Carrie's um remarks about type two
diabetes so type two diabetes is real
diabetes it's not any less concerning
than type one but it's treated often
differently it's treatable because in
type typ one's not
treatable well it's treatable but in
type one your body doesn't produce any
insulin anymore so you have to take
insulin right in type two your body
doesn't respond well to the insulin that
you make and eventually there's a
deficiency of
insulin but it's treatable in ways
besides taking insulin at least for a
while does that help at all it does
help but it to me that and
uh to me that still means you got to
monitor the devil out of this thing
continuously to make it work right for
yourself I think one of the biggest
mistakes from a public health point of
view in the diabetes world is thinking
that type two diabetes is less severe
than type one and not taking it
seriously I think that's I think you're
right I think that is part of the
word I don't have my folder from last
year with I've had to dig deep through
my emails to refresh my memory on
testifying on this uh last winter so I
just I want to just level set a little
bit because I think conceptually of
course we all want people with diabetes
whether it's type one type two or
pre-diabetes to be able to manage it I
have people near and dear to me in my
life who have diabetes we care about
this issue I think the problem is about
the language of the bill it is so Broad
and the scope of it opens the door for
anyone to get these devices and the
price is capped at $30 and so I was just
pulling up an email with our medical
director Dr lur who's been doing this a
long time and he said the legislation is
way too General um and it dictates this
sort of cap and availability for anyone
without clear guidance on it and the
jury is out on type 2 diabetes I think
my understanding is that in some cases
this would be appropriate in other cases
it's not and so I recall other carriers
testifying to this too that we
constantly update our clinical guidance
and Dr lefur noted that specialty
Societies in this space do not recommend
the use of these devices in all patients
with type two diabetes and this bill
would just open the door to that and so
I think that's our biggest problem with
it is that the language of the bill is
incredibly broad um and so I think you
know I just wanted to bring us back to
the sort of like actual language of the
bill and what it would do can can uh
representative Damon and and yourself
get together and see what where those
broad uh holes are that maybe we can
close up a little yeah and in my sense
is I'm not aware of there being like
some broad problem and this also in
terms of coverage this also brings us
back to the question of coverage and
benefit design issues versus no cost
share versus capping something at $30 in
statute we also get to the fully insured
versus self-insured issue so State
mandates only appli to the small fully
insured market mean not just small group
but the fully insured people in the
state which is getting smaller every
year and you know self-insured plans are
not subject to State mandates and so you
know if there's like a real problem in
this space I think we need further
discussion I think the way this bill is
drafted is so broad that that it just
opens the door wide open in a way that
doesn't necessarily even address an
underlying issue if there is an issue
again because of the small sliver of the
market it would even apply
to well I I it sounds like if those two
folks got together we might get
something that was uh more Compact and
more direct is that
possible um yeah
well I'm always happy to have
conversations
Anthem is always willing are and I
haven't heard complaints I'm sure you
know Peter and Harvard and and all all
would love to have the discussions so
but um I would have to say from what I'm
hear from representative Damon that any
any narrowing is defeats the purpose in
her mind and that is you've got to make
this available and and and and hope for
the best well and and so and and and
that's why I was trying to convince you
say that that's not when it comes to
health insurance mandates you know we
have this uh mandate that we're not you
know we're trying not to harm Insurance
Market you know with uh with with
something that could be very very
expensive or could not have any effect
and only a handful of people take
advantage of it um you never know what
what happen it seems that getting
something much narrower
through is better than getting nothing
at all right so if we can come up with
something that's direct and uh make
sense in the market that we have that we
can do without destroying our insurance
Market I think we got to go for it right
and so I I think in the end we can say
we we recommend further legislation but
only if the parties can agree on the
scope of what we're not recommending
this bill in its current form but that
if future legislation was addressed
these issues and you know the narrowing
in terms of what is it where where is it
that we really could have this benefit
and have an a long-term benefit um
economically for what it's going to cost
to implement it yeah I I think that sums
it up
okay then maybe we don't need another
then I
think from where we are in the time
scale of things November would be the
next time that you would be able to come
up with another piece of legis
but I think sticking Us in the middle of
it without you talking to like Anthem or
whoever is appropriate to talk to Anthem
is good because they're big I really no
I don't it's you two guys that have to
come up with a meeting not I don't want
to we shouldn't be in the middle of
this that's okay all right okay so maybe
we won't we don't need have another
discussion I
think uh you will see it in
January when it's been introduced but
you might get it early because she might
co-sponsor okay all right we all said
much
e
so thanks for coming I just talked to
Chairman hunties on his way and I don't
know if he was kidding but he told me to
start so I'm going to take him seriously
so
um I just move
this he stepped out he'll be back
um oh okay I guess we have to wait for
him there he is okay we have a qun so
we're here today um to talk about s sp64
um originally we were just going to talk
about manufactured housing but I believe
that we're expanding the conversation to
also talk about condo board
resolution um so Susan did you want to
say
something oh oh please we'll be out of
here long before that
absolutely did you know that um I know
Christmas so anyway um so we're here I
guess we'll start with the manufactured
housing and we obviously want to hear
what you all have to say and we've had
discussions um I know I've had
discussions with some of you um I've
talked with chairman hunt I've talked
with um representative melier and uh
representative Thaxton has been involved
and I know that there are serious
problems we we are not sure that it's a
legislative fix we we're not sure about
that but we want to explore it and we
want to if there's something that we can
do to help we want to do it so that's
why we are here today um so I'm
actually just debating whether we want
to um I'd like to if if he's on his way
upstairs I was going to start with
um Katie McQuade but um once you come up
thank you so much is this like a regular
hearing where we say where we're from
it's it's more it's we're more casual
here but um so I I'm a Manchester
resident I work for New Hampshire
Community Loan Fund I I don't really
have a lot to say about this bill other
than what I said um last um several
weeks ago when we were here about um
dispute resolution is kind of needed in
all parks both resident owned Parks um
and investor owned parks and condo
associations right anytime you have
people living together you need dispute
resolution um I would love to just turn
it over to some of the folks that came
we have representatives from um both
resident owned communities and investor
owned Parks who have a um a lot to say
about the bill and so is that okay if I
just yeah I was actually I was thinking
that before we do that I think I was
wondering Karen Susie does it make more
sense for you to talk from your
perspective or do you want to hear from
the other folks first
to okay all right then um um that that
would be fine actually um representative
Aly do you want to speak to um your
concerns or should we start with the
manufactured housing since most of the
that okay so who wants to who wants to
come up and speak first who's who wants
has something to say about manufactured
housing I guess I have to take take
notes my name is Patty Co I live in
Great Brook Village which is an investor
owned property in Belmont New Hampshire
there are a total of 65 houses there I'm
here specifically to ask the committee
subcommittee to add in investor owned
communities to the bill and also ask
that the board of manufactured housing
be brought back under the umbrella of
the office of Professional Licensing and
certification I understand that that
board was disbanded last year you'd
never know it because all the
information is still on the State
website it's all there so we sent a
complaint specifically about our park
rules and because that was what we were
told who would address it because the
property manager through the owner was
not taking care of our property so we
need a mechanism to be able to go to for
dispute over park rules rent increases
totally different
subject we've dealt with that also we're
still dealing with it to the point where
we now have an attorney and we're taking
him
through haven't got to court yet but
we'll be there soon if nothing works out
but my goal here today is to ask you to
please include all manufactured home
parks in the state of New Hampshire
resident-owned or investor and also to
please bring back the board of
manufactured housing under this that
umbrella of the office of Professional
Licensing and
certification and that's all I have to
say is I have to get back to work can I
can I just ask your name again so I can
get it down I'm sorry what can you tell
me your name again I'm trying to Patty
Patty with a Y Cole c o l e I live at 11
Lilac Lane in Belmont okay perfect thank
you I just it's hard to take notes while
doing all this but I will try thank you
so
next
anybody my name is Anita another Anita
okay that's right that's right and I am
living in ston Brook Park in seabook New
Hampshire inv own Park and I'm also the
treasurer on the board of
Moda and um I also am the person who
gets the email from people and this
manufacturing home ownership is new for
me I bought a home two years ago so the
whole concept is fairly new to me um but
what I'm understanding is that since we
lost the
board there is no place for people there
just is no place and the income uh level
of manufacturing homeowners parks areow
on the lower income I live in a 55 plus
a lot of them are 55 plus and so people
cannot afford to hire attorneys right
our association is having a situation
and the association hired an attorney
last year to deal with the Park owner um
and I'm not sure if we have some
resolution but we only have so much
funds that we can spend on an attorney
so I would also like to ask you to
please include investor owned parks and
of the um Gmail on the Gmail account for
moda in only the past two weeks I have
six complaints that I think are very
serious
four of uh five of them are uh co-ops
and one two no excuse me two F four of
them are co-ops two of them are investor
owned and one of those investor owned
complaints um is going to be to resolve
since the owner is taking no
responsibility it's going to be
extremely expensive for them to fix the
property which they don't even
own but the owner of the property is
telling them their driveway is their
responsibility and there's a defect
under the ground and um so they don't
have any money to hire an attorney and
she's got a handicapped child who is in
a wheelchair who can't get on the school
bus because she can't get down the
driveway so there are these issues where
we have a uh a document that we provide
for people that at Moda that's guide to
resolving disput
and we have two um recommendations that
are government agencies the office of
professional licenser and certification
and then the New Hampshire consumer
protection hotline at the Department of
Justice every single one of those people
have tried to make contact and have been
turned away we don't help you you know
Department of Justice will only get
involved if it has to do with you
getting evicted so there is just no
place for all these people to go and
with limited
income so thank you very much for I
just um you you mentioned Moda a couple
of times what does Moda stand for maybe
I missed that motor is um manufacturing
homeowners and tenant association we're
non-for-profit and Mota became sort of
defunct um many before covid
and uh the president I guess and like I
said I'm I'm only new to this so I don't
know a lot but um he died so and then Co
covid came and so things kind of went
down and it and so now we're rebuilding
it so we're still in the rebuilding
phase of trying to get members and get
people to um be part of a solution or a
help can you can you say again what Moda
stands for I was on the call last night
manufactured
homeowners and tenants Association am I
right yes
yeah thank you very much thank you just
go going back to this you you said uh
the owner the investor owners of your
Park said that the driveway is your
responsibility they said let me just get
is that any where in any of the the
documents that you signed
well I don't I don't have his full this
is from a park uh Interlakes mobile park
in Meredith New Hampshire is is where
this gentleman is from I know for my
Park um we don't sign a
lease but last year our landlord set out
all these new rules so he's revised all
his rules and in in in that it says that
we are responsible for keeping up the
driveway and the the walkways
which we read that meant you know we
need to shovel it and you know maintain
it now he is very clear my my landlord
is very clear that he owns the property
he owns the trees and you know nothing
is going to happen without his approval
we've got many driveways that are
falling apart he in my mind
he knows they're his responsibility but
they're not bad enough he's not fixing
them and we've got elderly people you
know disabled people and there's cracks
and he doesn't deem it need in need of
fixing and so they're not getting fixed
we have trees in the past year alone
we've had three trees fall on
homes he we have we're a park one of the
reasons I moved there was because of all
these trees it's a wonderful marvelous
Park but he doesn't make maintain the
care of the trees so he won't take
anything down that looks alive but um
he's not maintaining the trees so
they're hundred years old or more
they're beginning to die off you have
the there's branches just falling off
the trees I'm going to be going back and
battling because there's a branch that
is so dead and it's huge over my house
that woodpeckers are going crazy with
and all I want is for him to come and
cut that Branch off to protect my home
and he just doesn't seem too
interested can can hold on a second
representative do you have bylaws in
your yes we and have you read them the
association has bylaws okay he doesn't
uh Moda has bylaws yes but your Park our
he he does not have bylaws our
association we have the Stony Brook um
Association it's called salt and oh my
gosh I can't think of what salt stands
for land tenants Association but um so
it within the the park we devised a an
association in preparation if he has you
know we want to be prepared if he ever
wants to if this park sells he's I think
he's in his maybe early
90s and promises that the house is going
to stay in the family but we've started
an association so we can be prepared to
possibly turn to a co-op okay um so we
have bylaws okay all he has is
rules there is no
lease um assignment just a followup you
mentioned
that that's good you mentioned that
trees fell on some of the H do do you
know how that was resolved I mean if if
my neighbor's tree falls on my house I'm
going to sue him right no it's an act of
God and so you whatever you get out of
your insurance company is what you get
so as I was on that board until I had
resigned last election so I could be on
the board of Moda and you know I I
looked into what how much can you go to
small claims court and it's up to
$110,000 I I know that one of the people
had the tree fall it was in the middle
of like a typhoon she called Mr Brown he
didn't even come and he said it was a
Friday it's like raining like you can't
even believe and he said I'll I'll I'll
have somebody out there by by
Monday now a tree's on her house the
rain is pouring into her home and he's
not going to have some a tree guy till
Monday so she had the tree removed and
another tree that they deemed was dead
and it was $3,000 just to remove those
trees that's and he said you didn't have
my permission to remove the trees so do
you have a lease no we do not have a
lease we have park
rules park rules set by the owner owner
yes no lease just you're supposed to
sign now I refuse to sign the lease
because when we hired the attorney the
association hired the attorney to
address some of the issues in the the
new rules for instance the trees I mean
there's several other things but and we
had a special meeting and he came with
his son and I caught him in an outright
lie but um nothing was resolved
and so I told them I'm not going to sign
your rules until you resolve my concerns
so you were asked to sign a lease and
you didn't I did not sign a lease there
is no lease there are park rules that's
very different than a lease so I didn't
sign the rules and not there are no
repercussions I mean overall I'm very
satisfied with him I think we're he's an
a I think he cares a lot about his
property and the people why this tree
issue is I'm not really sure and the
other issues that we have just business
right right he's a businessman you know
so um but you're putting people's lives
now in danger as far as I'm concerned so
that's a
problem yeah so um I've been doing this
a long time and uh I'll never forget
this this is going to be almost 30 years
ago and the issue that you brought up
about how the AG doesn't want to get
involved unless someone has been thrown
out well you the AG would get
involved if you had a
lease because they would be treating you
like a renter and we have very extensive
statutes on renters
rights
and much to my surprise when we were
going through this type issue the state
of Connecticut mandate
that you have to have a lease MH and
that was the
resolution for your situation which is a
you know privately owned Park that if
you had a lease then you'll know how
much the increases in the rent will be
you'll know you'll have everything know
and if and then in there will clearly
State how they're going to deal with
driveways or
trees yeah no but we can't make him I
mean I don't know if he perceives this
the new rules to be a lease in my mind I
mean I've been a homeowner and owned
income property I think there's a big
difference between some rules and a
lease oh there is so he we are not
signing a lease we are acknowledging his
rules
and some of the rules that that I
engaged in disagree with is he wasn't
so and he said his lawyer put this whole
thing together and I said funny I was
told
by I think somebody a Community Loan
Fund that this is basically does anybody
remember that that the what what he had
is is written up by the Community Loan
Fund like like I I don't know remember
rules but he basically copied and pasted
someone else's document um and a lot of
it so
um he's he's backed off shortly after I
noticed I did notice a lot more of his
tree guys around town you know around
town taking some trees down but the
association put together what we call
our tree form and it's kind of a map and
you know to submit it and we are just
trying to get people to put everything
in writing and have your documents so if
the only thing is really open to you is
to take them to small claims court well
at least you can do that but if you if
you're just complaining yeah and calling
them and complaining without a paper
trail we don't have any way to um really
protect ourselves so I'm working on that
end
there oh
sorry hi hi uh
so I guess I have some questions about
your
testimony uh the
you know one the kind of going backwards
in
it you said you're something about the
rent increases it's my understanding
wrongly but rent increases are severely
restricted in manufactured housing Parks
I didn't bring up rent increases oh okay
I think they're I think they're
restricted to $15 a month per year
unless you can justify an increase right
so you'd have to be have you'd have to
show us documentation taxes
or something went up right so you're not
you're not you effectively have rent
control on mobile home
parks
uh
the I'm not sure what it and in New
Hampshire there's no requirement that
leasees be in
writing so if a landlord says to you
with a normal rental interval which is
30 days I presume in your
facility uh they give you 30 days notice
that as of 30 days from now you have to
mow the lawn as an example they have the
ability to do
that um so I'm not
sure the rightness or wrongness of it
the economics of it are outside the
scope in my opinion of what the
legislature should be involved
in I'm my concern here is
that uh I think you have remedies to
this I'm not sure what remedies you feel
you don't have you have the same
remedies that any other tenant has you
can go to landlord tenant court you are
a tenant in fact mobile home parks have
a even greater constraint on them than a
regular
landlord uh you have there's greater
constraints than just under
540 uh a which is the mostly the
landlord tenant code so what I'm I mean
I hear things that are probably
legitimate problems you're concerned
about a tree falling through your roof
or he doesn't maintain the driveway and
I would perhaps he should or perhaps he
shouldn't and maybe he maintains your
driveway but not her driveway I those
are all individual issues but I'm not
and so I'm not understanding what remedy
you were looking for from the Le I mean
I get what it is but I'm not sure why
this should this group should or this
group of citizens should have a greater
protection than they already have since
they have more protections than uh a
regular tenant in an apartment building
or a single family
house in fact your your landlord can't
even sell his Park until it's gone
before for the Community Loan Fund and
they've and and the tenants do or do not
want to buy it so he's he doesn't have
freedom of sale so I'm not I'm not
really
sure what more you
want what what you know now he's mean
and
he's that's what I'm hearing here I
think you have all those protections so
okay that's my concern I think there's a
different set of concerns which will
come up later with homeowners
associations on Condominiums and things
and that would then also apply if you
purchased the park if it was a co-op
then there would be Association rules
there but again all these things are
provided for in normal landlord tenant
law they're also provided for in
association documents if you purchased
it so I'm not sure why we need
a i the the the mobile home uh committee
whatever that commission right was
they they did away with it because it
had so so such little
activity well I will speak to that yeah
because it was our Moda was defunct for
a little bit and so a lot of things were
coming through Moda people didn't even
know it existed and then covid happened
and everything sort of shut down so you
know that's part of it the question I
have you make a good point I I've never
heard of the landlord tenant you know
system certainly um I have not heard of
it um in Moda but you know where would
that fall for us that there is a a park
is being sold and it the property is
um I'm just making up numbers but I have
a neighbor who's a realtor who just
brought this to my attention as as an
occasion who this is happening I don't
know what park it it just got sold but
the the value of the property was
something like $1 million sure
and a um Investment Company came in and
paid 24 million so the people who were
trying to make it a co-op can't compete
with that and they are you're you're
giving we're closing the door of any
lower
income possibilities for people to be
homeowners and it's under the way it is
right now is you're comparing to to what
it cost to rent and if we don't have
that nobody's going to be a homeowner in
the economic um category of lower income
people and how can we compete well now
now you've taken now you now you're on
another subject but I'm but wouldn't
that be a part of the mediation board
that's no that's not what this is about
and and the proof is in the
pudding if you talk to your friend
behind you from the Community Loan Fund
they do these things all the time I can
tell you that in chesher County the
majority of the mobile home facilities
are now uh owner
occupants
so and by the same token you said you've
owned a house and you've owned
investment property I imagine you sold
some or I imagine you sold that for a
profit at some point one of them I did
yes okay good
and I wasn't a landlord on that one okay
but you your house you sold it a profit
so the question you just asked is the
same question is if we turned that
around and said if you had sold it for a
lower amount of money then you could
have broadened the pool of people who
had who could have bought it and
wouldn't it have been nice if somebody
with less money had been able to buy it
that's not how a market economy works I
understand so if you take the the net
rents on whatever they are on your your
facility that was up for sale that you
referenced and divide it by 8.5 that's
your sales price that's a 8 8 and a
half% return on investment that's a
conservative
number uh
so I don't
know there's nothing in this bill first
of all would that I as I understand
would get involved with the sale of
properties and if it did I would object
to it even more streng uously so we're
really at what point at what point do
you want to move out of a market economy
I mean if you want to move out of a
market economy and have things allocated
and controlled by the state then you're
headed in the right direction if you
want to live in a market economy then
this is not none of this is what you
want there are Bad actors there are Bad
actors in
everything there are good actors and
everything probably neither of them get
enough credit
but uh you make a very good point and I
I understand what you're saying so
that's you know those are those would be
my concerns with us okay thank you can
you tell me again what is what is the
landlord tenant 54a 54a yeah it's a book
good if you buy it as a book it's that
thick and that is landlord tenant that's
landlord tenant law law it's under the
uh Attorney General's office and um
there is a free mediation service yep
okay so so you haven't tried that no I
haven't even heard of that again I'm new
to New Hampshire two years and things I
don't know but um I thank you I thank
you for even listening to me thank you
very
much I actually have a question for the
chair but do do you have to don't roll
your eyes at
me do you know um you mentioned
Connecticut I thought was interesting
they're mandating a lease y do they
also have some specif I can't ever say
this word specifity in terms of what
needs to be in the leas or is it is it
broader do you I have to admit this was
a long time ago so I have no idea okay
what the but that that the end of the
result was that most people do not have
leases and those are those can provide
protection and so over the years when
we've dealt with this legislation you
know we did have the you know price con
have some board that was approve rent
increases and that's when we learned
that you know said why would you have
this in your lease when you buy the you
know when you rent you you know you're
it is true you're buying your unit but
you're in the end of the day you're
renting the space and so what you know
what what controls do you have over that
the landlord and that and generally
historically the landlords have always
been uh
um I guess you would say that they were
U gentle with their raises and gentle
with it and then you know when it got
really bad then obviously we had the
Community Loan Fund
stepped in because the and everybody
said well the answer is that you need to
own your own Park that that's the right
answer but as we now know about the
other bill is that owning own Park you
know you know comes with a consequence
of of uh some elst group of people who
run run the park and and and ignore the
rules and do whatever they they want to
please and and uh so there unfortunately
there wasn't a lot of Perfect Solutions
here well it seem I mean it seems to me
that that might be an Avenue to pursue
about the leases and very frankly that's
going to be dependent the chances of it
going through on which political party
wins in November and I won't say which
is which yeah so I would say this is
issue could last a lot longer than our
political cycle and it's always been the
assumption that eventually all these um
owner parks are slowly phasing out and I
mean I know Jensen's at one point in
time had you know like a dozen but I
don't know how many they have left now
but so slowly but surely there that the
the those parks are slowly moving on to
thanks to the Community Loan Fund so
whether that's the right answer or not I
don't know it's it's it's always it's
always been a problem can
I uh two things in in terms of things
that have to be in a lease under New
Hampshire law a lease is subject to New
Hampshire's statute of fraud so it has
some basic things it has to contain be
included right be included but other
than that it's whatever you and no it's
fair game with the rest of rest of the
stuff that's in there but if you don't
have lease well then you have a you have
well I I'll I'll never forget it it was
all it was uniformly from Moda I'm
trying to remember the lady who used to
run she used to be Lois yes and uh she
was here she was camped out this in the
in the committee all the time and um but
they she made it clear that they were
not interested in leases because they
always thought the the problem with the
lease was then it's going to be written
right into it how much the rent
increases are going to be and how much
you know that and that and that that
some landlords would go a year or two
and maybe not have any increases so to
them at least was was a bad idea that
they would they'd like to they like the
fluidity of you know let's see how we're
doing and how the park is doing and how
you know and that the landlord was just
going to be you know pass on those
expenses that that needed to be passed
on and uh so it you know it ironically
there seemed to be Hermon you know that
that it wasn't that bad but obviously
when it got to it you know got ugly and
when we had you know property tax
started to go through the roof that's
that's when you know we Rec created the
the landra you know to get to give them
a way to afford to be competitive to to
be able to afford to buy the park back
and for themselves but not withstanding
if somebody eyes that property to make a
lot of money you know you know turn it
into something that they thought they
could make a lot more money on it yeah
you're not going to compete with that
and and now you've thrown you know x
amount of people out on the
street representa uh just maybe you can
give a little more clarification on a
540A now do I understand there is a a
complaint board or no no where did that
come actually we had a bill this year
dealing with the landlord tenant yeah
it's called landlord tenant court but
it's easy to it's it's easy to go
into uh it's it is designed to be where
is this though this is not under 548 do
you remember the discussion this year
where we had about uh trying to get a
tenant out of a house that refuses to
leave remember having that floor debate
I don't remember that no okay well five
4A is everything that's landlord tenant
related in New
Hampshire all of which apply to mobile
home parks right and then they have
another set of statutes that are on top
of that that are specific to mobile home
parks they're but so just within the
parameters of
540A the
tenant has the opportunity to petition
landlord tenant court to
rectify whatever they're issue the
landlord has got a free he's endangering
my life that's a bad thing so they can
go in and for $60 go into district court
and say Here's my case this is why they
have to make some kind of case out of it
but well is is that the answer that
we're looking for I mean if these people
well then maybe it's as I'm saying it's
sitting right before us POS possibly I'm
I'm I'm baffled that they don't go to
landlord tenac court it cost 60 bucks
has anyone who's
nobody's heard of it okay so you haven't
utilized maybe that's the problem well
I'm sure your landlord hasn't told you
about it but I'm sure they know about
it I mean for for 60 bucks um we don't
have to reinvent the wheel no the cord
will type up the the service for it does
here pull the Y
oh I mean it's not like one liner it's
like
is is there any arbitration it's
mediation yeah it can't be it's
mediation yeah well that's thing
arbitration okay the judge will say you
go out in the call and talk about
this okay let's let this gentleman speak
name did you turn your
there you go sorry I think my
Cooperative is an example of of uh of
democracy and a and a resident own
Community uh it's it's uh it's it's a
pleasure to live there now I am a member
of motor I'm uh also been the president
of my own cooperative for 10
years uh and I served uh on the
Community Loan Fund board of directors I
served on the Rock USA board of
directors I served on Rock associ ation
which is resid own communities Across
America and uh I've I dealt with a lot
of issues that surround democracy and Co
and cooperatives and and how to help and
support them a great piece of news I
heard today was that uh because I deal
with with investor owned communities as
well is this this uh RSA
540 uh which I don't think anyone was
that aware of so thank you for that uh I
go away have Having learned something
today uh the only issue I have is is
that is that RSA
205a which is basically for manufactured
housing uh to have a uh an oversight uh
committee or an oversight organization
such as the manufactured housing board
uh is an important piece but I think
it's an important piece for it's there's
an RSA and there needs to be an
enforcement wing for it and uh and it's
and it's and it's and the
RSA
covers resident owned communities and
investor owned communities and I think
it would be it would be a little bit
discriminatory to to only do one only to
to uh uh have enforcement for one part
of that organization I think there are
needs on both sides of that there I am
certainly in favor of it because I think
there are there is Need for uh conflict
resolution in communities and but it it
doesn't make any difference whether it's
manufactured or a resident-owned
community or an investor owned Community
we all have our issues and and uh would'
like to see some
organization that would that motor
could could uh give information to
people so that they would have some some
form of resolution to conflict that
they're
facing uh you know in this day and age
is affordable housing is is is depleting
the largest stock of unsubsidized
affordable housing is manufactured homes
resident owned
communities
uh are are notorious for keeping rents
low because they don't have any
investment uh uh I should say return on
investment uh need and uh I can tell you
that my community went a period of 10
years and and had only1 $10 increase in
their rent we have a lot of folks there
that live on Social Security and they
can afford to live there
but I'm hearing stories of invest
investor owns investors buying
communities today because they are they
are a top dollar they're paying top
dollar and in order to substantiate that
they have to raise the rents beyond what
people can afford I'm hearing stories
today of folks that have to move out of
their homes in New Hampshire because
they can't afford a $1,200 lot fee when
it was 500 3 years ago that's a travesty
and it needs to be dealt with and
perhaps this RSA 540 can help out with
that but in any case my point is that I
think that you've got an RSA that
doesn't have really any teeth to it
because there's no enforcement for it
and it's I think it's discriminatory not
to it's it's it's designed to protect
all manufactured homeowners whether they
live a resident own or not and uh I
think you'd be dis discriminated against
one group if you didn't in include them
thank
you thank you so much I actually I'm
want to direct this to representative
Faxton you know I think one you know we
oh Jesus what the heck is that that's my
phone I thought it was a pager I got
scared um I blow up on you yeah I know
um you know representative Mair talked
about mediation versus arbitration the
difference is mediation
tries to bring the parties together
arbitration a decision is is brought
down so even if they go to landlord
tenant
court well landlord tenant Court's
binding on both parties how is that I'm
just I'm trying to understand if it's
mediation how is it binding well it's
not it's not mediation if you go to
landlord tenant court the judge gives
the judge is going to give you the
opportunity typically to go out and work
it out in the hall okay okay and then if
you can't come up to an agreement then
okay Dad's going to make a decision
that's so it is Bing that's correct okay
involve any any of I I well no I I would
have to read it no cond are not Brant if
you read the definition right there you
can read it out to
everybody who is a
tenant tenant means a person to whom a
landlord rents or leases residential
premises including manufactured housing
or a space in a man manufactured housing
Park
yeah yeah thank you very much and just
just so we're clear on 548 it it's a
there's a lot of Statute there it's not
like that was one little s that's one
little sentence there's 200 Pages well
no there's not well there related which
your reading is all the case law all the
case law comes back to it yeah which
speak iita durett again you know to
speaking to that you know I have read
205a and I'm an educated college
educated person and it's
almost unable to comprehend so I'm going
to look at
540 there are people in these places
that aren't going to be able to read
this stuff and comprehend what it their
rights are or what it means and they're
going to be going to to the
court by themselves most likely because
nobody's going to be able to afford an
attorney and you're going to have the
landlord there with their attorney
and the difference again between
arbitration and mediation least you go
into mediation and we have landlords
coming in and they're not even following
their own lease and so as far as rents
are going and I just think it's not fair
to the common man to expect them to look
at 540 you know whatever it is and 2058
to to be able to comprehend exactly
because you don't write it in English
you're writing it in some kind of a
legalistic you know writing that unless
you go to law school it's very hard to
comprehend and mo our motor meetings we
set aside a part of our agenda for them
to go through that
205a with us to be able to explain it
the guy down the street in their house
does not have that benefit can can I can
I interject that that sounds like it's a
good project for Moda to try to dumb I
mean I I I don't mean this in a
disparaging way because myself as a
legislator sometimes struggles with some
of the legal ease um to dummy it down so
that everybody it's real easy read
simplify it okay I shouldn't have used
the word dumb D because that's I think
of dumbing it down for me no I meant for
me dumming I understand and if we had
such a document that would be awesome
well uh I I agree with both of those
things uh I many years ago I worked for
an insurance company and they decided
that they were going to simplify the
English and their policies
which no one knew what they meant then
so mhm
uh
the there's legal aid
available and I would well many of your
points are well taken you know the you
know the guy who doesn't have your
educational background looks at this and
says what does this all mean but that's
the but that's the situation for the the
single mother who's a high school
dropout that's renting and has a Section
8 she doesn't know what her rights are
or may or may not not so there are all
I'm saying is you're missing a whole big
section of rules that are open to to you
and if I would suggest that since you're
very involved in this if you go online
to Lexus Nexus buy their book on New
Hampshire landlord tenant law it's it
will cost you 75 bucks but get the
association to pay for it y thank you
thank you but it's not just single
mothers who are on Section dat we've got
I I I completely agree with you on that
I'm just using there there are inherent
inequities in our system everybody can't
win or correct so the so the design of
the system is to provide provide
guardrails and make it so that it's
everybody has the same
opportunity I mean I I used to like the
bowl when I was a young man and you know
bowling with the bumpers out like you do
with your kids I mean that's really not
fun right but you win better it's easier
to win right that is the point yeah or
you lose or you lose right if you're not
as equipped as the landlords are you got
to you got apples to oranges it's it's
it's a con it is a constant challenge
but there in this room from my
perspective our issue is do we need
another piece of legislation which is
potentially redundant or is it is it the
matter is the matter that you have
opportunities that you don't know about
and aren't using or do we do is there
something missing and my point would be
it's not that we're it's not so much
that we're missing something as that
there's opportunities that you're not
aware of correct and that would be on
the end of in landlord tenant owned but
now you've got a law sole set of laws
RSA 205 with zero representation for
rock
homeowners that doesn't make
sense that you would have laws that are
to would you just go over that one more
time you're saying you have rocks are
the homeowners the co-ops yes so you've
got RSA 205a that are the state laws
governing manufactured
homes without a governing board or board
that oversees those laws
the laws are really
mute well the they're not laws at all
unless you got a lot of money to hire a
lawyer to go you know go up against so
representative are you saying that it
applies to those folks as well you
always you can you can go into District
Court I mean again it's if it's a land
dispute it has to go into Superior Court
but this isn't a land dispute this is
still you know I I guess I'd have to
hire a lawyer to sort this out
what it is but again I would think the
association would have some kind of
counsel but what happens when the
homeowner has to go up against their own
board that you got boards that are rogue
I mean there it's it's not an easy
answer I I had a thought on that
previously which is you know how first
of all how many of these boards are
rogue I know I 5% of them 1% I mean and
which isn't to justify a bad actor who
but if you're if they're if they're
violating their
own
agreement that's a contract and so
you've got you you certainly have the
Civil option but at some point if it
truly breaks that breaks that contract
you also have the you should take it to
attorney County attorney yeah cuz every
place we've gone to that we've known
about to lead people to wants anything
to do with them well I believe that
County
attorney how how many and I'm going to
put your name attached that you
suggested these
things how how many how many members of
are there of
Moda right now I think there's 39 so we
are building from the ground up 39
people or 39 uh uh let me say
30 36 people and four
associations how do you become a member
just pay your D pay your $25 dues or um
the parks pay 75 and we have
institutions that would try an
Institutional um membership uh for
things like Banks and attorneys to be
part for their own you know because we
need lawyers we can't even get lawyers
to to represent us they don't want
anything to do with this issue we have
someone that has been spent a week
calling
you know because now you're getting into
land stuff and that goes on for years
and we have lawyers out there who don't
want any part of it we've we've sent
them to the um um your suggestion of um
legal
aid I believe I'm not sure if I remember
correctly but I think they were
interested if you were being evicted if
you're not evicted they're not
interested you don't you thank you very
thank you very much for that's real
helpful and I'm gonna I um I stopped
because I'd like representative Aly to
come up who may have some some more
issue well there were a couple of things
that came up um one of them is that the
manufactured housing board was repealed
a few years ago on the woman that was in
charge of the office of professional
licens and
certification left to become a judge
last week I believe it was and there is
a new uh sheriff in town there and she
um would she was thinking she'd like to
renew that but then she thought or they
told her that you are now just
professional lure and certification so
it can't be here on next year I'm going
to be putting in a bill you're going to
hear a little bit about maybe uh
afterwards but you've heard a lot about
it already and and I had found a new
home for the condominium dispute board
which on is the uh Department of
administrative services and Charlie
Arling house said that he would do that
at the time so um I've got to go back
and talk with him
about the manufactured housing board
because really it did work itself out of
a job but then we got two new things
happening one of them is that the cost
of any housing in this state has gone
beyond our worst nightmares or biggest
dreams depending on where you are in the
income scale uh and the second is that
um people from Mostly from out of state
came in and start all over the country
and started they started in the west
buying up manufactured housing parks and
um getting rid of the people that lived
in them by raising the rent so high they
couldn't afford it and then turning them
into whatever they wanted for that
particular piece of land and yes that is
part of capitalism but capitalism from
the beginning has always been considered
to be necessary to to put guard rails on
it so that um
people people from all levels of society
would be able
to uh survive and to
provide manual labor and to provide uh
for the elderly that fell after working
as a middle class person during the most
of their lives um
into to
poverty and
um at least the volumes I've read um but
the other thing that um I wanted to
bring up was that I have also never
heard of this um I I heard a little bit
about the possibility of mediation in
landlord tenant
uh at the time I was looking at this I
also heard that uh the landlord got to
decide which court it would be be done
in that's not correct that's not correct
no the court okay court system is based
on the town that the property is in
Period end ah and I was told it was the
town that the owner was in no it's it's
where the property is located okay
that's that's not well that's good
that's of course but the other problem
is our court
systems and our AG's office and our
County
attorneys and
um and certainly the
um the legal aid people are all
underpaid
under resourced they don't have enough
people to do all of the work that
they've got already and that's why
they've been
existing um adding extra stuff on
there and especially when
it's not related to what they've been
specializing in which is apartment
buildings they they have their whole
it's if you go into district court in
any County in New
Hampshire it's got a special window for
landlord tenant
court they're already set up for this
it's like they knew you were coming and
they baked the cake okay so well I think
everybody should go and look at that I'm
going to go I've got to go up to Grafton
County in a little while anyway um I'll
I'll be looking at that when I was 20
years ago working on a different project
and spent a fair amount of time there I
never saw that window maybe it's new
well
I but maybe they just maybe they just
put have it in chesher County but I
doubt that yeah um
but it does the other question with that
is how long is it going to be before
they can schedule that
hearing because the problem we have in
condominium problems is that the person
who or people who are
complaining tend to get
persecuted during that time until
decision is made
sometimes it's fairly violent
persecution but well that's a that
sounds like a police issue but the the
dockets and courts vary from season to
season and year to year in court to
court but again only speaking from
personal experience in chesher County
you're generally on the docket within
two to three
weeks that's very good I guess the
people in nashwa should move there
please
not representa can I ask you quen you
you mentioned that you're going to put
forth this bill for cond dispute board
um are you planning to include the
Manufacturing Housing in that or not uh
I'm going to have to talk with some
people about this it's just an idea that
came up but manufactured housing has one
Corpus of Law and Condominiums have
another but it may be possible to put a
bunch of this stuff
together uh in separate sections with
the existing housing
court I think that would be uh an
interesting Avenue to pursue absolutely
yeah I have a question for the
representative you you referenced
earlier people coming in from afar and
buying up uh mobile home parks and
driving up rents Etc and I want to go
back to the earlier testimony which we
all seem to agree on is the limit on
rent increases is $15 a month period the
end a year not $15 in May and another 15
in June it's an annual rent increase of
$15 a month unless the a greater uh some
new and interesting cost can be
established that's in privately owned or
investor owned Parks so for $180 a year
I mean I understand that if you don't
have a dollar it might as well be a
million dollars but $180 a year doesn't
seem like an excessive
increase uh now I know that in
in my area where many of the Parks have
been sold to the owners or the tenants
the
owner tenant owned Parks whatever
they're called but owner resident
resident own oh resident owned Parks so
and and I know many of them were shocked
at the cost because where the former
owner was charging $500 a month now the
actual operating costs are $800 a month
uh with management fees and paying back
the loan and whatever so that's the only
place in my area that I'm aware of where
we've seen huge increases in the monthly
fee to the association but I don't know
how how how an owner could legally raise
month I find that
completely um impossible to explain why
why would an
owner uh a investor invest in a property
and pay $113 million for it or something
like that because it's near a lake um
and not expect to be able
to to raise the rents a lot more than
what you're saying well I how are they $
that was the testimony in this room
earlier today I mean it's that's the law
Hampshire it may be the law in New
Hampshire it may also be not
enforced well it would if if that was
the case if if you if you lived in a
park and the law New Hampshire says I
can't charge you more than $15 a month
and I justify it and I raise it $300 a
month you have zero chance of surviving
in court that's clearly the County
Attorney but you could go in there
prosay and that is that just can't stand
stand they couldn't throw you out for
not paying
it they can't well it's like you can't
you can't you can't you can't if if if
if somebody writes I remember a
policeman in my town once somebody came
and filed a bad check claim because that
he had they had written a check for
purchasing marijuana and because you
can't you can't make that claim if you
took a check for
marijuana if you're breaking the law
you're breaking the law so you can't go
to court and say I like this part of it
but not that part well this this is very
interesting I will um be looking at that
in my own area um we
have one
rock
and about a mile down from it there is a
a resident a um tenant investor tenant
in which is not what I would think of as
an investor it belongs to a 93y old man
who uh they think is a pretty good owner
unfortunately when he
dies on it will be up for grabs and
right
now these these places are
across the road a busy road but across
the road
from Moma
Lake uh and the first rock in there
managed to Miracle to make it to make it
work um
but but that was six years ago eight
years ago um and now now the cost of the
land itself is
probably up around those 10
10 10 million
whatever um just because of the place
that it's
in so
um yeah you've raised a lot of of issues
that I want to go check on in another
County because Cheshire is one of the
it's part of New Hampshire it's part of
New Hampshire and we're part of New
Hampshire even though people think that
we're part of
you're going to pursue that and we'll
follow that and see see if there needs
to be a separate bill um on that but
thank you so much for for testifying
today oh and I did I did want to also
say to agree that we really if you're
going to have an oversight board for
rocks which are already
overed by by the Community Loan fund we
certainly need one for the uh the
otherwise owned if which would include
the one owned by my my friend down the
road from the rock that is 93 years old
and may die at any
time okay thank you very much
representative um Karen Susie do you
or no I didn't I wanted to know if you
wanted to
add no that's fine I just I just want to
know if if repres I'm not ending it if
you don't if you don't that's
fine
representative can ask a question of the
audience is is there anybody in the
audience who lives in a manufactured
home that has had a rent increase above
$15 for the year so there may be a law
but it ain't working no the law has been
repealed
she's not in a private par she's in a
community own yeah she's in a
rock so if I can interject yes please
there's a lot going on here okay um
Karen Susi represent the New Hampshire
manufactured housing Association okay
manufacturers installers private park
owners okay um we have a lot going on in
this discussion first of all I would
like to hello Anita you and I would love
to chat I'm delighted that Moda is back
I think it's wonderful that the
residents are now speaking up for
themselves rather than the lender I
think it's wonderful I had a great
working relationship with Lois Paris who
led moda in the past years before she
passed so I welcome that
opportunity very important for residents
to have an open dialogue with Park owner
very important
um I'm hopeful that if you get back to
Senate Bill 64 and you want to talk
about the resident-owned communities
perhaps Moda might be able to come up
with a dispute resolution
program you know I would hope that
residents if there are issues in
Resident owned communities that the
residents would want to resolve
them
okay uh you want to talk about now did
we go on to the board of manufactured
housing um that was actually repealed
last year not years ago it was repealed
last year uh that was because um I think
2019 was the last time they had any
complaints and most of the complaints
that they received weren't within the
jurisdiction of the board to be able to
handle so didn't have a lot of action
going on first of all the New Hampshire
manufactured housing Association had
nothing to do with that being reped
appealed we did not suggest it it came
down from the top and down just like
everyone's getting rid of boards and
everyone's making them
advisory okay so go for it who
specifically uh dissolve board the
governor this legislature did you voted
to repeal it yeah I think it was on
consent I can't quite remember the
consent
calendar um what else can I say I think
there are a lot of B actors in The out
there in every industry in every aspect
um but again if Moda would be
comfortable reaching out to me if
they're hearing about an issue in a
privately owned Park well then by all
means reach out that's what Lois did not
a not a big deal I've got a business
card um any is there anything else I can
answer for you want to talk about rent
increases yeah what okay let's go rent
increases
um so I think it was in
2019 that someone came forward it may
have been represented D David luno uh
proposing h a rent control bill for
manufactured housing parks for privately
out
and rather than do that we offered as
the
association to have our mcap program put
into statute okay and that reads that if
the
rent increase is more than $15 a month
proposed right
so if it goes over 15 the residents can
petition and get
51% signatures from the park and move
forward with um a uh
mediation and I'm trying to think what
else but oh something to keep in mind
though that
$15 which is still in statute today that
2005 so that's which that's a pretty low
threshold
yeah okay so but the one that we
repealed what that what RSA was that
that was also in 205a I believe the
board of manufactured housing yeah so
who would who would mediate that
so we have a mediator that the
association pays
for as long as
so I'm
sorry sorry folks uh the New Hampshire
Manufacturing Housing Association I'm
happy to meet up with you after this
okay very good um could could not a
mediator be a a first choice for these
people to go
to and I mean okay are you now you I'm
okay now we're kind of yeah what what
are you focusing on well we we've got
folks that are in these uh associations
whether they're privately owned or or
investor owned and they have complaints
and they they don't have the money to go
to a lawyer why not have some sort of a
mediation board and now you're telling
me that there is one for some issues why
can't it be extended for other
issues okay so the mcap program the the
lot rent increase um for private Parks
that's something that we pushed forward
did to on our own that we pay for the
mediation okay as unless there's a park
who's not our member of our part of our
association then that Park owner pays
for the mediation so that's something
that we put forth now if Moda wants to
put something forward that says hey we
want to come up with a med
Ator wonderful it's you know residents
should be able to take hold and move
forward with that I don't think that
private perks should have anything to do
with any type of oversight of Resident
owned communities this is something that
the residents should have control over
not the lender not not privates but the
residents should have an answer have
something to help themselves move
forward the only reason I'm here is
because I kept getting the calls from
the residents and Resident owned
communities that's my only reason for
being here I I have a question for you
when you talked about your mediation um
for the private Parks is there any teeth
in that I mean if you have an owner who
says I'm not going along with
that okay so no there it's not M so
mediation is non-binding right it's not
arbitration okay so if for some reason
the residents don't like the outcome
they can go to court
vice
versa okay any any other any other
questions who is
funding
thisi like who is funding who do you
work
for
okay sure so her questions are first who
correct so I'm Karen Lucy and I
represent the New Hampshire manufactured
housing Association and the association
is comprised of manufacturers of homes
privately owned Parks installers lenders
uh insurers I pretty much represent
industry okay let's let's let's uh let's
try to let's come around so do is there
anything else that you'd like to add at
this point no okay not at all thank you
so much I think that clarifies sure
thank you and is I believe there was
some other person who would like to
talk
sir yeah good afternoon my name is David
DWI from Belmont I live in a park called
Great Brook
Village uh I'd hear I'd like to address
a few of the issues that have been
brought up here uh this one that we were
just talking about was
mediation we had a rent increase
imposed last year we disputed that rent
increase it's a uh investor owned Park I
should
say so we filed the necessary paperwork
to go to mediation which was offered as
a as a way to resolve this
dispute
we got the necessary signatures from the
homeowners we arranged the mediation
as it turns
out mediation was not successful we did
agreement I and one of the other
homeowners represented the homeowners in
the
park the management company was there
representing their side the owner the
state as it turns out the only thing
that the management company had had to
do was not agree to
anything so as far as mediation goes it
turned out to be a waste of time frankly
the
mediator I'm sorry I can't remember your
name right now the mediator brought the
proceedings to a
halt and she finally said we're not
getting any answers here I'm going to
bring this to a
halt the management company
stonewald did not answer questions again
and again and
again the management company would not
mediator when he did say
something it was a series of
unintelligible
phrases that made no
sense and he would ask after saying this
does that make sense in the mediator
looked right Adam said no please answer
the
question this was not once or twice this
went on on and on through the whole
almost three hours of this
mediation so we followed the program we
went to mediation mediation was of no
use that disputed rent
increase is still in dispute today we
made it very clear after the
mediation that we're going to pursue it
further it was not
resolved and after listen to the frankly
gibberish that we got during the
session my
only my analogy I'll get off the track a
bit bit here my analogy
is if you remember a comedian called
Professor Irwin Corey who talked in
unintelligible phrases and he made it a
a funny presentation that's what this
guy did for for the whole uh session of
the mediation so mediation was not
successful after the mediation was
completed I called
mcap said we did not come to an
agreement what is our next step what can
we do next and the reply was we could
hire a lawyer very
expensive but that's the only option
that we had was to hire a
lawyer we are presently involved in
another rent
dispute we got a rent
increase effect of January of this year
some rents increased 22% someone else's
was 16% someone else was was 19%
year-over-year
I happen to have in my rental
agreement a clause that limits the rent
increase to a certain formula tied to
CPI CPI plus 2% to be
exact the management company does not
follow that they do whatever they want
to do legal or illegal
the rent increase effective January was
much more than that allowable
amount many people uh had a much much
bigger rent increase than I did there is
no
consistency to the rent
increase there is no consistency to the
new rent that a new tenant would
pay so there are a couple issues
involved one is the amount of a rent
increase that is allowed and thank you
very much for the information about
RSA
540 but the rent increase is one issue
the other issue is the
abusive practices of some of these
investor
owners that are raising the rent for new
want for a park like ours the current
rent is approximately 5 to $600 a
month depending where you are depending
on the
park our rent is now for new owners for
new people moving in our rent is now
$1,200 a month 11 $1,195 a
month so they're heaping these new
extremely high rents on new buyers new
tenants new
residents in addition to that the latest
tactic being used is they're making the
rent agreement a month-to-month rental
agreement so for the lot
rent they're offering the new residents
a month-to-month rental agreement to
rent the lot that their house sits
on this is this is
unconscionable how can people pay a
month-to-month rent without being
assured that they're even going to have
a a place to
live
so they're essenti making the houses
worthless sales have stopped virtually
$1,200 a month
rent potential buyers are just hanging
up the phone and in walking
away a month-to-month rental
agreement this is making impossible to
so that uh the rent increase is one
issue but the abusive practices driving
the rent so high that people can't sell
their place is putting a financial
burden on someone who may there may be
people who are depending on the value of
their house maybe for their retirement
or whatever it may
be uh so I lend my support to this bill
establishing the committee not only for
resident-owned but also for investor
owned parks and if that's a method to
help people resolve these disputes to
make sure that the landlords in the
management companies abide by the law if
that's a way to get information out to
people and help them resolve these
disputes then that's why I favor this
bill uh quick question sure the the rent
that you pay is that for the home or the
land or both it's it's a lot rent just
the lot rent I own the home okay I own a
home the rent is for the lot rent thank
you
thank you so much that was helpful that
information anybody else would like to
sir we blending it or we want
to finish this one up and then start up
the other okay so we're so we're going
to finish up the if nobody else has
anything to say about this um sorry I'm
not talking into the mic um I think that
what our committee needs to do is is
reconvene you know there have been you
know a lot of good suggestions about um
you know um solutions that may be
available that people don't know about
but I think uh our committee needs to
also explore possibilities of of any
legislation that might be possible it
may not but I think we need to take a
look at it so um I think then we'll end
this part of the hearing and we'll move
on to the condos
thank you very
break
for
e
hey let's get this show on the
road or road on the
yeah
okay well you were part of the uh
discussion of including condominium you
wanted to include um condoman disputes
yes I just thought that it would go
yeah it's like soup and sandwich so I
mean is there a specific bill that I
know that you would you had wanted to be
here is there specific bill that you
wanted to discuss or upcoming
legislation
okay
sorry Susan elme on city of Lebanon
Grafton 17 we got redistricted and I'm
the
float uh and um also one of the authors
of every single one of those bills
that's come come through and so you
should know quite a lot about them by
now and you could see from the previous
discussion that there are a lot of
people in a lot of places that do not
cannot figure out how to get adquate
legal representation to be able to use
the option which is taking it to a court
um we had early on two guys from a
largest Association condo association in
uh
nashwa on who were on the association
consisted of a main block and then an
extra block they tacked on and they were
in the extra block that they tacked on
and um they were all paying the same
fees but they were getting a lot less of
the stuff they needed done like like
fixing the the Flor or that fell in and
things like that um and they had enough
money they took it to court said they it
cost them two years and
$20,000 to complete the court case and
when they completed it the judge looked
at them and said
sorrowfully I think that you've really
got a problem here and uh I can't do
anything about it cuz there's no condo
law that was early on and that was why
we started putting governance law into
the Condominium
Association on law which was originally
just to catch bad actor developers that
were selling to people coming into
Condos for the first time that is the
condo was built and those new people
were coming in and to protect them from
bad actor developers there must have
been a lot of them at that point I guess
because they put that law
in
um
and but since that time there have been
years when nobody showed up to talk to
us about their problems
um some years where we managed to help
solve problems uh and the people went
away happy and some years when we could
not do that uh and people a number of
people said that they were leaving New
um and then last year when we had a
totally new group except for me and and
we sat there and the chair uh
representative
infantine uh decided that we ought to
listen to the six people that were there
in front of us they were from three
different
associations and um had three
different kinds of problems that were
all pretty uh
mindblowing he had never run into a a
badly run Condo Association before he'd
been in them
and I have not have not had those
problems in my homeowners association
but there are a lot of places where
where people fall through the cracks
there are also places where we get
complaints from people who who want
their neighbor to be told that that they
shouldn't smoke on their deck cu the
other person's allergic to smoke and
that kind of thing we can't do anything
about I call them the pink FL Flamingo
bills requests so and
but we really need some kind of board
like the manufactured housing board was
the manufactured housing board did um
put all of its decisions into the court
the court took the kept the decisions
filed for 6 months and then entered them
in as case
law
and the um what was then then not the
oplc on took all of the decisions and
put them up on their website in a
prominent
place and my opinion of why they ran out
of things to do was that they'd run out
of most of the things that could
possibly
happen until
till the cost of housing and everything
started to change everything um but the
current new head of the
oplc
um does not think she can take this the
manufactured housing board back she
thinks some version of it should
continue um and
she uh has committed to keeping that
website and putting it in another more
prominent place
again if we manag if we decide that we
need to have a manufactured housing
board as a subsection of maybe the
housing um
board um while we're deciding about
Condominiums um that's something that
um that that um could go along with the
manufactured housing board which would
probably be limited to very rare
occasions when they have to talk but
maybe not it sounds like things are
really changing a lot again in in
trailer
parks and so anyway on the condominium
side on we
have no higher authority except the
district court
s and the district courts are
overwhelmed and the people who can
manage to find a condo lawyer and uh
your chair gave me a list or got me a
list of the lawyers that would listen
and I called all of them
and three of them said that they would
talk to a
condominium group or o or owner that
were um were trying to figure out what
to do um only two of them had and they
um listened to them and then
commiserated with
them but just told him sorry uh nobody's
going to take that case one of them um
the best one of them actually in my
terms in terms of of being understanding
about the problem uh said that what
you're talking about is not about enough
this so um I didn't get terribly far
with that except to can little inform
you to ask a question do you know how
much money um it might cost to to
reinstitute Institute a
board yes you got a fiscal note right
here
excuse me excuse me the fiscal note is
from the previous
oplc right person who also these numbers
look a little high yeah they are
definitely High she staffed entirely
with
lawyers we wanted
one the the the place had the board had
manufactured housing board had been
staffed by one
uh at first full-time and later
on part-time on
clerk who was
on figuring getting in all the
complaints on classifying them according
to topic and then um putting out doing
the minutes of course and putting out
the the uh call for the meeting
to to the heads the the owners of the
manfactured housing board and the the
uh on
complainants and and then um taking
minutes at the
meeting and that doesn't need a law
degree right right
and the biggest problem that I've I see
in doing something like this is is that
the condominium
law is a very large
chapter and so um we're going to need a
lawyer who is as the manufactured
housing board person was uh doing
thinking about
retirement and understand and has done
some condominium work that would be on
that board so bottom line representative
is that you want to move forward with
this bill I am still you're still going
to do that looking to look forward move
forward with it representative infantine
wants me to finish writing it first and
then decide whether he wants to come in
on it and um Whitley had who was on the
committee has uh moved on so at this
juncture
what what if anything do you need from
us other than to wait for the bill to
come out to to take a gander at it I
don't need anything from you I was kind
of surprised you were having a meeting
about it again but but it gives the
opportunity for this gentleman to talk
to why he thinks we shouldn't have it at
all so okay so we have you wanted to
speak sir
I
sure what's it
yes oh I wanted to know that that's real
that's
true well good afternoon hello my name
is uh dick sweat I'm a resident of The
Vineyards Condominium Association in
stratum New Hampshire we are a
Condominium Association we are governed
by RSA
356b and after hearing the tales of the
manufactured housing people I certainly
think that combining these two types of
organizations is not a good idea I mean
we have totally different uh uh
structures uh we have uh our ownership
is is different our our uh problems are
different I just really don't see a
combination of these two groups I think
they should be separate uh the man
Manufacturing Housing board should be
under their RSA condominium should be
under
356b I've lived on a Condominium
Association for 16 years I've uh served
on the board for six years I was
president of the association for four
years I'm presently uh chairman of the
condominium Leadership Council and I'm
also representing the New Hampshire
legislative action committee today Gary
didario couldn't be here either could
Don lenon they asked me to step in there
in their shoes uh this bill HB uh 1645
as representative alme said has been
around for a number of years it's also
very similar to a bill that was passed
in in the senate senate Bill 324 in the
2022 session and the house committee
declared that bill as inexpedient to
legislate this bill that we're looking
at the 1645 is quite similar uh to that
bill uh I think one of the major issues
we have here is
that the RSA
356b said promotes the concept of
self-government for Condominiums once we
get into a condominium dispute board I
think we are taking away that concept of
self-government uh during my years of a
board our our resident disputes have
been settled within the framework of the
condominium
declaration the condominium bylaws and
the rules that's how we have solved and
settled our disputes on the members of
the
condominium uh dispute board I think uh
we have to think
that Condominiums are not all the same I
mean there are
owner occupied Condominiums my
Condominium Association 76 units is
totally owner occupied uh we and that's
how we govern ourselves there are other
condominium units that have investors in
them they do rentals uh either on a
lease for a a year if that's what the
bylaws call for or they could even do
vrbos which can cause problems for the
Condominiums and uh they're also the
seasonal owners there are tension in in
these groups the seasonal owners the
investors like low monthly fees whereas
the owners want to maintain and have
preventive maintenance issues to protect
their investment and they like to have a
good solid Reserve account if to have a
good solid Reserve account you're going
to be paying higher monthly dues and
that's what some investors see looners
and other people don't want I would say
the procedure to follow to file a
complaint with the dispute board uh
really bypasses the framework of
condominium declarations condominium
bylaws in our rules I think the idea
that there's going to be a mediator
within the dispute resolution board uh
kind
of Intimates that the board might not
want to handle all disputes and if they
send them to a mediator as somebody
pointed out a mediator is not binding
they're not an arbitrator they are a
mediator a mediator also charges pretty
heavy fees for their time so that would
be an additional expense I don't think
the procedure timeline for solving these
disputes is particularly timely I mean
it it it's something where these
disputes are going to go on for a
considerable period of time I think
there's one issue in here that's really
quite Troublesome and I'll read this
statement the board meaning the dispute
board shall not be bound by common law
or statutary Rules of Evidence but may
admit all testimony having a reasonable
probative value it may exclude evidence
which in the opinion of the board is
immaterial irrelevant or unduly
repetitious that's the end of that quote
and I don't think this provision does
not provide sufficient checks and
balances for this board's
deliberations I think the initial
determinate unit owners can complain
about the boards but can the boards
bring a dispute about a particular unit
owner to the board for resolution uh the
initial determination about the validity
of owner complaints are made to the
dispute board but before the association
receives any information about the
owner's dispute where is the
transparency here uh the dispute board
will receive legal assistance provided
by the Department of Justice condominium
boards appearing before the dispute
board will probably have to go and get
an attorney to advise themselves as
they're going to be having an attorney
opposing them from the Department of
Justice which is going to be uh advising
the dispute
board
um I I think uh all in all the dispute
board really doesn't have any full
remedy I mean their remedy is to file uh
uh uh a uh an appeal with the superior
court and then the Superior Court would
then enforce the re the the decisions of
the dispute board I mean this is kind of
circular in a sense because if you do
have a dispute that's where you go you
go to the superior court of the district
court so um I I have to say that uh the
establishment of the dispute resolution
board would bypass a concept of
self-government set up a time consuming
procedural process attorney
Fe and services and remedies would be
dis administered by the Superior Court
the court that presently handles such
disputes so the organizations that I I I
I represent really
uh one would
not agree or would like to see a
combination of manufactured housing and
condominium dispute boards and two we
think the RSA
sufficient framework with which to solve
disputes and also it's very difficult to
get people to run for the board of
directors and if people do have
complaints they should run for the board
of directors in our Condominium
Association we have term limits on the
board just to uh make sure we have board
turnover but anyway that is my
presentation thank you for listening to
me do
respect uh representativ Al's thoughts
about needing protection for some groups
but uh I think the I think the size of
these condominium associations is is is
important too they can size can run from
two units which are called conexes you
know they're like duplexes two units
conexes they can be under RS
56b to units of five 500 units so this I
I don't I'm not sure this dispute board
is really a sense of where it one one
shoe fits
everything that's my testimony thank you
very much any questions
folks thank you thank you so much for
your testimony and I guess we will We
Will on this bill we will wait to see uh
what representative Al me is going to
present to the legislature next
year so just make sure well I mean what
it would be the status of HB 1645 I mean
is
it well I guess it depend if but
hear it's dead but but representative
Aly can do a new bill I understand I was
just I just didn't quite understand what
the pro I didn't understand what the
procedure was here but I mean on the
octob there's a meeting supposedly on
October 17th where the full committee is
again yeah yeah that's I didn't know it
was the 17th
what happens there
nothing so there's no need for anybody
up so I mean the bottom line is that
it's going to die and then you know rep
the representative can pull out of you
know the last bill what she chooses to
and to presumably make some changes to
it representative Aly will will be
submitting a new bill exactly H HB 1645
is y gone okay thank you very much thank
you so much appreciate the understanding
of this okay thank you okay yeah
representative little piece of news uh
the condominium with 500 people in
Freedom on both sides of it want the
condominium dispute for at this point
and they'll be they would be here
talking except I told them in study
doesn't mean anything yeah yeah and I
and I do I just to end and this I would
just say that there are some uh there
are some bad actors in condo your your
Association ones well others don't where
they're bad actors and they need
something like this
so I'd just like to add for that one
that
the on both sides of the
freedom
argument on have a point okay that's
good to know I hope that you're going to
listen to them carefully when they when
we put in a bill to try to thread the
needle and they'll each of them be upset
a it absolutely thank you so much okay
we're going to end we will end the